reasontv presents citizens against
government waste sparker of the month
New York congressman jerrold nadler it's
fast it's expensive it's a missile
besides the Chrysler Building high-speed
rail long range field service that will
never pay for itself will come close to
paying for itself Money Train Vice
President Biden recently announced a
proposed 53 billion dollar spending
spree for high-speed rail projects I am
very familiar with ray didn't we already
spend money on high-speed rail in the
Obama stimulus package Julie eight
billion dollars so we Recovery Act got
it eight billion and now you want
another fifty three billion that's
that's money
so a lot of money you don't know the
half of it Transportation Secretary Ray
LaHood said the administration's plan
for high-speed rail would cost 500
billion dollars over the next 25 years
and these projects are notorious for
cost overruns remember the government
saying Amtrak would support itself
within a few years that was nineteen
seventy last year alone Amtrak cost
taxpayers over 1.5 billion dollars in
subsidies the only thing you're good at
is losing money I think you can figure
out how I lost mine so while many
lawmakers are rejecting the plan
congressman Adler is clamoring for the
cash many of these states demand
politically demand the service and
frankly they're entitled to nothing
stops the money train so you have to
subsidize it no mass transportation
system in the world makes money my train
my people my money you can't have it for
nothing because what's another five
hundred billion dollars when total
national debt exceeds your gross
domestic product you're in debt up to
your eyeballs we're gonna own our kids
let me train for more information about
four per of the month and other
government waste issues visit CA GW org